Salaam alaikum so we go again and
company love going live here in New York
to bed I know some time ago I was really
surprised was a good surprise it was a
huge billboard and ever some Hadid write
some teachings of the D on it and then
come to know we got the hate monsters
here tell us how did this come up world
hates Israel increases busta hate yes it
was the name of love yes and flood
that's the gold necklaces to bus came
with well so coming up in a bus is
actually initiative that we had a new
york signal center five years back when
we first started and we actually put it
out some ocean once we saw the chapel
games chocolate errors occur when the
free believers Barbara Millis personal
done by me the answer was that right now
it's her exactly happy there a chapel
hill and when we saw that it was
basically missus on Tina cause that and
said you know what we can or will now
chugalug p posters so we went full force
of Java and we want a couple of hey
Buster trucks as you mentioned a boss
the truck's actually have a little more
loving message that shows for sure
different perspective and the best thing
about the naplex the trucks you can't
get away from right is drive by you side
with 20 we have to read the sign sao
paulo and actually one of the trucks
engaged a lot of people in amazing
amazing results in order for was the
kind of response for me like to say you
just need you to pay you came to huge
what is it like 10 by 10 and it's huge
myself definitely he was younger you
know we went zooming all over New York
City mashallah New Jersey went to
Maryland and each of the responses have
had one common theme which is positivity
you know the people we're all nervous
here right and the American people they
actually actually what Islam they
actually need to just see what a perfect
example of it as easy a good examples
and when we went around like scum I
reckon here near city right around we
actually stopped at college campus right
and a professor a woman professor
stopped by a truck so what's this about
right and hadith of the Prophet peace be
upon him it retina the best of you are
the best tours look okay so the
professor Kane wants to try and i will
send everything some shots right some
college embassy kids no shelter
too and she was like how come you guys
don't do this son hmm she asked us to
how about you guys don't act the
coordinate system and I asked her simple
question I said well according to WHO
according to the media well if you want
the true example we look so where is the
true sense and you know we're actually
going to be questioned right whether its
own on sweaters our you know how to
spout whether it's our mothers whether
it's our daughters we were commanded to
be good to me and you know I talked with
her a little and literally within like
two minutes hate was busted because she
was like you know what wow so glad I met
you and you're not really happy make me
do this to the boy and she had system it
was actually sure that it played she
actually gave testimony to testify that
this isn't possible issues The Hague was
busted hate was busted a nut shell no
ghost both motions other hate book yes
this is a must see a lot more hates best
you guys are continuing you have some
more good words but yeah so we had a
total of two trucks so far here to make
monster trucks one of them they actually
did a very amazing initiative where we
put a thief of the Prophet peace be upon
him we're in since that time you know no
glasses superior white or white series
of lock door knocks or not
except by righteousness except by
example right and we did was went out to
behind when I was new york city
manhattan to park the truck put it right
there cameron from the truck and we had
about 15 rows exactly it was about 50 or
201 and others dismissing me now we have
whole buncha roses and we talked to give
of New York City I was holding hate read
this sign they would be the sign that
the prospects of then we asked them do
you agree with this and they say
actually agree with this so you had a
section on the truck that I take picture
we gave them a rose to show them that
this is what his sons really about and
it was mind-blowing was we started
getting out the roses all I was like you
know gold whole bunch of people came out
to see what we were doing and we turned
so many people into lovers of the
assignment supposed to you know what the
unfortunate media propagates itself we
were in New York now this is our
neighbors of trumps they are both hate
most important Trump Plaza yeah so
actually Trump announced its presence
the answer and that chakra so but we did
go to kind of affluence there requires
in front of class news and you know it's
a couple
we disagree as a Greek money did [ __ ]
[ __ ] news or even other major video if
you got some nice fresh and I really no
they're not looking too I'm quite sure
if it goes on throughout their [ __ ]
hate with love oh this is not good for
anything we can see for that but you
know we definitely move forward okay it
continues it reminds me there is a I
chapter 41 30 degree of time on an
episode of Homeland redundant wrong he
was assaulting an apology anything else
to do does this go with that name talk
about the past those who call to this
way purano p ism being on purpose of the
Creator sat down for all the messages
including Jesus Moses Abraham they all
carcass intimacy submit to the great
American Krishna do good deeds this hey
busting goes in line is very active as
suppose any deceit very much about some
in some of email and say some patience
is the fobian how it goes like we
mentioned in the a.m talks about doing
good to Ingrid and part of doing good is
the beginning of having just a
perspective having
I think or a reference right which is
the vehicle of it I'm not just doing
good because you know stay close
speedway today I'm good but I'm doing
good not just one time to continuously
because there is somebody out and really
in the best way and so my physical being
my actions everything has to be good as
well we're here with hate buses were not
necessarily in terms of dour we're not
reading went in the wheel or putting the
wheels in motion of doubt or going out
there where they know but it's now were
propagating the truth correct release
but it's not we're trying to tell people
don't judge it sound by those hair
apples of those bad examples judge this
land buying the best examples like the
problem tomorrow by the people who
practice is now properly in their life
because if we just go either dyeables
that we're going to be negative we're
believers look at it bad apples of every
society bad examples for every society
and then it's just a matter of bickering
and fighting each other what we're doing
is what's in that nate love or say hey
this is the teaching of islam this is
what God wants a super investing in be
every hustling and our manners in our
dealings with our within our communities
within our families within our extended
communities our workplaces our schools
come on and so forth so that communities
and societies can come with it it's not
there's a person game it's for the game
of anybody right just me myself at night
it's one for all but you guys dealt with
any people came up to you and try to
associate rom like media has with people
being barbaric they hang people Isis you
know many of these negative stereotypes
that are associated with it
I'm not seeking everybody was
surprisingly people understand many
people Iseman understand that what they
see on the users actions and when they
see the pictures on television tells my
name and that's how to put it in some I
met many people who say this is us and
they say that I know what it sounds I'm
with some friend time for some neighbors
that show me what it sucks so although
we have this wall or the kiss barrier
that status that's a huge burden a huge
one robot or I think this initiative in
a lot more people will be able to
understand that the Sun is what they
somehow heard from their families our
neighborhood somebody they're like as
holding something beautiful and not this
thing that the media media wants to
portray on the side I like this concept
of a crossroads of love how important it
is it for every individual to take the
matter seriously reports of dialogue
sharing and bus they hate with love as
individual and as a community some is
very important because if examples right
so many people accept the assignment has
simply do the examples of the people
that were in funding if you be by
example people will actually walk to
what your problems what's your show
little people and you know one of the
biggest things in regards to pay
Buster's is exactly that anymore the
greater community to understand that
every person is on the muscle right
every single person is a composer in
their life whether it's in the workplace
whether
restaurant whether to deal with the
waiter weather every aspect of life
you're a tease because the reality is
right if people you know see you and you
know the big beer and you don't feel
they see that the Muslim idiot driver
idea how somethings about you will have
to be in you know by your character and
by your example and it's very surprising
ocean as it's a doctor mentioned that a
lot of people actually said those exact
words that you know we know that this is
not sure the song ever written in
Baltimore were a little truck we were it
was great fun story smiley writing it
and stop the change you know some of the
like I think something got loose and
we're trying to change the trying to fix
it one day when I should came by and he
was an American right now I was slimmer
and you know he saw the truck and we
were reading the actual initiated
conversation he came to us and himself
as those exact words that you know what
I know what they're saying about you is
actually I have a lot of people some
friends good Muslim neighbors and this
is how we show people with truest honest
when we deal with our neighbors in the
right way when we feel with others in
the right way you know hate busting is
actually something the problem he see if
I'm right it's actually a prophetic
tradition of the bunker when the Prophet
peace upon him when he went to [ __ ] life
was the major city outside of Mecca he
went there to try to see if he can stay
here the situation is very hard in my
right he was no being a beauty here
being portrait lives are being lost
right this isn't something new and I
couldn't jump a little tightening for
right and the Prophet peace upon my hair
the leaders United the people that I him
they threw stones at him he ended up
bleeding he ended up hurt and his wife I
shall ask him what was the hardest day
in her life was it one of the battles
right was it
was it but what these battles and the
profit is the army said no the hardest
day in my life with the de atacama the
day i thought when i was denied by the
people it was a look for the Prophet
peace upon he was denied by leaders and
I by the people the children were taught
some stones ahead it's like he's outside
nowhere else to go this and at that
moment he was asked by the Angels do you
want to take these two mounts an
impression right now what is the proper
bcoz Scism perhaps from their
generations will be people that do not
punish my evil today open up the
probability being hit and he says
forgive might be before this day all
know so the sunnah of the prophet Micah
prophetic tradition and we're tossing
this one is actually scalable and to us
the hate of month before we conclude
what what's up at the end of the day
with the main message that people want
them to take away from the hate mustard
campaign so the heat Buster's mention
has one major goal which limits and
Zionists on eight or helps women right
and when we want people to interact with
us to see our trucks in to engage with
you know our material in our people you
basically want them to understand Doug
look we're Americans just as you
Americans right where the sun's in you
believe in your own face that's not a
problem right everybody has their own
beliefs but we don't hate you we don't
hate you no matter what that you know
media or anybody else says we're not
people who hate we're actually people
who love and it's an our tradition to
love others and to help others
regardless of their faith and we want
people to understand that
son we won't even understand that you
know Muslims are good humble you know
people that are basic maybe slip to the
neighbors young people's trust as the
Americans this long each other right
there in the name it's line says love
all mankind we have their love for
mankind we're bustin hate with love in
New York City things yes cuz I'll keep
us in a good hug is applying some be
okay